assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends before I start want to place a
loss of Hannah what's out of the most
merciful the most trust or praise His
glory and gratitude belong to him for
the works at Salaam studios that were
doing
for with you guys believing in us and
helping us and making this happen
inshallah our video colors are going to
increase I'm gonna bring you better
videos with crisp sound hopefully and
better quality insha'Allah today we are
discussing something very important what
is that we'll be talking about
wifebeaters yes you've heard this right
brothers and sisters wifebeaters those
people who beat their wives yeah so what
we're talking about are we talking about
in the Quran Allah Fontana says that you
know beat them you know this one far I
always use it against us which we've
casually and smoothly destroyed and
debunked you know with Muhammad hijab
and shabu Sophia and his book that's
written called the woman in the text
which I recommend for you guys to read
this mountain in all these kind of
claims so now if you guys remember I've
had some altercations with the far right
specifically specifically Britain first
yes now there Britain lost when I
confronted them if you guys remember and
you're gonna see the footage for
yourself when I went there you saw Jada
let's start at this table renfa let's
start with poor Golding and Jada
Frandsen both in prison I think so both
of them so if you remember when I first
went to them she was insisting why they
shake my hand why don't shake mine why
are you shaking my hand good show man
wanna shake man she was so obsessed with
my hands and I started to think to
myself I know your hands might be very
special because you know not only Jada
and a few other far-right fan fan girls
but even
Lauren sovereign from Canada at a debate
and kind of got the shot with the
arguments was constantly asking to shake
my hands I was starting to think my
hands are really special so they build
that confidence within myself I want to
thank you for them
but the point that I want to make today
is this Jada was literally dying too for
me to lay my hands on her hands
literally not knowing behind those
you know that face you know was abuse
was mental torture was physical torture
a recent documentary that came up showed
that poor Golding used to beat be I'm
talking beat yeah I'm talking slap up
hit look her in the room Chiana this is
how she was treated Jada if you're
watching this shame on you you was
crying and doing backflips yeah because
I didn't what I didn't want to lay my
hands on you while poor Golding was
laying his hands on you in a different
way and this is how allah subhanho wa
taala exposes people someone like you
who's going for that abuse you have the
guts to come and tell us Muslims about
treatment of woman okay okay
hope you all recovered mentally you know
a man like that who a friend he was a
boxer before is that coward for putting
his hands on any woman and today we're
also going to learn which I'm gonna come
to later about how the Prophet
sallallaahu sent them which these people
always constantly attack how he treated
his wife's so since we have discussed
Jada and Paul we're gonna give a few
other individuals from the from the far
right and you know we're gonna do we're
gonna talk about the best man that
walked this earth the prophets Allah God
will send them and these lot were
attacking him but now they're eating
their words why because we're going to
learn how he the Prophet Allah was
telling the man these individuals
criticized and these hypocrites are now
eating their worth and we're gonna find
out how he treated his wife's brothers
and sisters now let's go to number two
number two who were talking about now
hmm we're going to be talking about Tony
Robbins and somebody who had a who was
who's got a charge and assault charge on
him yeah what he was doing he was
abusing his wife yeah and I have no
doubt this man is most likely cheating
on his wife yeah most like cheating on
his wife and was abusing his wife and he
police undercover piece of the game and
he attacked the police officer because
he came to break them up Tony Robinson
talking about woman's rights these
hypocrites absolutely hypocrites number
three who's on our list well recently
recent discoveries you know we had this
feel free a vile animal who clearly says
that his shoes shoes innocent
Palestinian children have you saw people
like this guys he claimed yeah and he
got destroyed in an argument yeah we
sent him packing back home yeah I was
making water Allah to send this man to
me and hand about was looking I saw a
job hamdulillah and when the Germans
that way I saw a little kid little child
this little boy a boy you're a boy
you're finished you're finished
hahaha this is you know one token oh if
you don't know then you guys need to
catch up with updates so this little boy
at the Yemeni yes he was course yes and
I call him and I said oh Allah we
destroyed him into pieces handle with
the permission of Allah
and guess what this guy's been doing ok
come and tell us about the Prophet peace
be upon him and he was like there's a
news like that you animals Allah he
mediates you guys I lost one tell
humiliates you guys and not only that I
wouldn't be like you called the Prophet
peace be upon him a pedophile will have
dismantled and destroyed these claims
yeah destroyed his claims and it's all
soon we're gonna be having events
because we claim your faith when we go
through all these doubts and it's all
gonna have you guys coming up that's not
the topic yet and you guys have called
him a pedophile I was AB in luck you
look at you a lot punished you guys
again how one hundred percent of the
pedophiles are white men middle-aged
white men you come at a repeater fight
but most beautiful look like you yes so
this IV here mini guy he's been throwing
choppa throwing I think this in big
knife or a chopping board or something
at his wife and he got done for assault
you
hypocrites this is how Allah exposes you
look at you
Tommy Robinson poor golden jada jada
shame on you you're a woman you're a
woman you should have known better and
this little child
little boy yes they say to boy every
Yemeni yes all exposed yeah not only
that most likely you know stellar you
know the beer can Stella you know a stem
is known for what it's a wife-beating
drink
yeah how kawatche meeting they say the
ones who drink the cellar they go home
and beat their wives yeah and look at
recent look at statistics yeah how many
woman get abused by their husbands and
their boyfriends why because their
football team lost and also there are
yes there's no denied there are some
Muslim men who also do this and that is
wrong but the plane were making here the
point that we're making here is that
these people would always criticize the
Prophet peace be upon him now
look at the prophet sallallaahu seldom
make soup on Allah please look at his
life in the treaty of hudaibiya yeah
when the Sahaba were enraged and they
were not listening to the Prophet peace
be upon him he got advised from one of
his wives he said look I think was he
did know what to do cause he's that
they're not listening to me yeah and he
said well you know like nations before
were destroyed for not listening to
their prophets
yeah I was in sample room behind already
corrected myself and she said look he
always consulted his wife she said look
go you shave your hair they'll do the
same how it consulted his wife a teacher
and allow Anna when he was getting ready
he would run to her and she would be
their companion to him
and he loved her so much this is how he
was with his wife one time the prophet
sallallaahu seldom brought some kind of
a food I think from one of his wife's
have sir so if I'm still houses house I
think one of his wife's he brought the
food and I shall I do Anna came to the
room and she got jealous she got just
what does she do imagine imagine this
Tommy Robinson is a VM aney and this
poor coating imagine their girlfriends
that they beat up and their wives that
they beat her bliss right-center
imagine comes and I should I demand her
bought the plate and smashed it on the
floor who won't you do yeah your Muslim
brothers what would you do you would
lose the plot how dare you embarrass me
in front of my friends god knows what we
you would have done have a go I'll
shower
well this Tony Robinson every minion
poor coding would probably beat the crap
out of them and lock them in the room
and God probably tortured them what did
the process sallallahu wasallam dude
look at the example of this man wallah
and you death tell us you dare tell us
that he's a man that he was bad to his
wife's what Allah he never a burden ever
he said you know he said to a Sahaba he
said your mother has got angry imagine
your mother I should have got angry can
you imagine that smashing the plate your
mother's got hungry can you imagine I
was a sisters
mother sisters can you imagine the lab
that he died on I shall rather and has
lap he died on he would have races with
her yeah he would not races with that
once he raced with her and she won and
later on down the years he raced with
that and she he the first I'll sell him
beat her and even joked earlier and said
I'll you know you've put on some weight
he would drink from the same Cup from
the same place same place as her mouth
same place when they would watch I think
there was there was a tribe doing some
kind of a dance or something like that
the action of the Anna's cheek would be
on the first on selim cheek yes she was
somebody who learned from foursome
she is one of the biggest scholars
female scholars in his time that
narrated thousands of a hadith this is
how his character was and let me tell
you what is more profound and they dared
to come and tell us that phosphorus Elam
look at this when I shall when I shall
and her was slandered and surah Noor
came down defending defending her honor
and telling the believe a man a woman
why did they not think the best and was
spreading this rumor look at this the
first one Selim came and said I shall
honor because this was going on too much
and first of all he's a human is well
yes he came and he said look imagine
imagine this year imagine like obviously
you know you're not seeing that your
wife has committed that but look at the
four sons Merce he said I shall go oh I
shall if if if you have committed this
act your Lord is most forgiving turn the
repentance and if you haven't indeed
your lord almost of Hannah Ouattara will
send down what he to defend you
can you imagine if somebody came and
said accession said sure about your wife
what does it maybe yeah you would lose
the problem if you believe that in your
heart like that believed or had some
kind of a sugar hat as a human being you
might lose the plot God knows what the
personal son says look if that's
happened something disloyalty yeah it
the magnitude of any man he says if
you've done that your own circuits
repent
look at that look how kind he was when
he would come to home and do his own
sewing he would help him clean around
the house as well yeah he would do
things this is the man that you guys
dishonor and as you dishonor him allah
subhanaw taala humiliates you guys you
humiliated upon humiliation upon
humiliation and this is nothing less
than what you deserve yeah
the process seldom is back to his wife's
here look at you look at you hitting
beating throwing troubles at your wife
shame on you guys
and hamdu lillahi rabbil alameen this
Deen is the Huq this Deen is the truth
brothers and sisters we ask you to hold
firm unto the religion of Allah subhana
WA Ta'ala because these sugar hats these
lies are going to be spread except for
those who are firm who have yaqeen who
are certainty and what Allah he we do
and may Allah keep us firm on this
religion this video is to show you the
beautiful character of our process Selim
and the evil people how Allah exposes
them one after another hope you guys
have benefited in each other if you have
do support salam studios inshaallah
these works that we bring home the
liberal and sisters we are getting
professional people to come hamburger
we're getting good media team graphics
light everything
salam is gonna be taken to a next level
inshaallah even branching out to turkey
that's what yes you heard I know also
let's not forget the beautiful brothers
different organizations that I era do
beautiful work also support them
till next time brothers and sisters and
Salaam walaikum what happens when I
better care to may Allah bless every
single one of you guys for watching